hello everybody my name is markiplier
and thank you all so much for 9 million
subscribers now this time I'm gonna be
doing something a little bit differently
than I have in the past because
yesterday I found this subreddit called
our roast me and it was really funny
because people volunteer to be roasted
or insulted on the internet by all the
commenters and when I put my picture up
yesterday I wasn't sure how far it was
gonna go but all day yesterday my post
right there is actually was actually
number one on the page so I made a point
to not read any of them so don't take
anything personally this point in my way
because I am here to enjoy it and I
can't wait to read it I have been it's
been killing me not to read these
comments I really really really wanted
to read these comments so badly and I'm
so ready to right now so without further
ado I'm going to go now so as you can
see they called me a celebrity on here
and listen oh my god tastes like Marc
says Wow even your handwriting is loud
and obnoxious hey just put a good title
up there you got your attention this
one's my favorite all this got me more
who are you that's good enough for me
you look like you talk during sex oh so
talks to himself oh that's so brutal he
probably asked the girl to tell him how
much she's going to watch his videos and
subscribe don't know I'd hate to see you
cry like you do in every single [ __ ]
milestone video you posted boost your
massive ego no offense but you kind of
look like markiplier it could be worse
he could sound and act like markiplier
too oh my god the best joke in this
thread is the mods tagging a mess
celebrity I completely agree with that
one how is it being beautiful beautiful
I that still lives with his mother
hi I moved out of my mom's house a long
time ago daily not lately
more like weekly fitting you took this
picture in front of the shower
it's the perfect backdrop for being
water
stuff oh man you're faker than my
girlfriend's breasts and I made her up
just now oh my god that's this is so
clever ooh
discount beauty pie has made an
appearance if we're doing celebrities
now call me when someone who doesn't
rely on 12 year olds to get their
paycheck shows up you're a creepy [ __ ]
you look like you sent heart emojis to
your 12 year old niece when you tell her
to be confident in her body oh can you
do worse [ __ ] duck the dill holes
even use clickbait outside youtube I
just want this it make a good title you
look like you got declined a job as one
of the Wiggles and YouTube was your
fallback plan actually I'm wondering if
this is the right image yep it is oh
damn it's too small this is big I was a
wiggle I was wiggle hidden bar bakers
music video I was oh my god I wish I was
brave enough to glue pubic hair to my
face but hey with a smile like that it's
not like you've mattered anyways go back
to swooning children on YouTube Oh No
your nigahiga before he made three
wishes for YouTube fame good looks and
his parents love you like the one
direction or Jonas Brothers of YouTube
just not as famous or as talented your
emotional videos are so over-the-top and
obnoxious they make me cringe they
remind me of a 12 year old girl who
cries just for attention I'm surprised I
don't see more of your videos being
posted on I'm 14 and this is deep you
use clickbait as much as your video
suggests you pander towards jailbait you
got a voice like butter though must be
where all your testosterone went because
the only person more girly than you on
YouTube is Shane Dawson what the hell
you calling girly boy I've never seen
such an unwarranted celebrity tag if you
did an ama the first question would be
who the [ __ ] are you
the second question would be where did
everyone go
you have both a voice and face fit for
radio ah don't you have more 5 nights to
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] nuts videos to do or
are you working on another pandering
milestone video filled with crocodile
tears
to get the ten to fourteen year old
tumblr users that comprise your viewer
base to feel better about their
imaginary problems I guess judging from
the down votes in this thread looks like
marks rabid fan base
creepy deaths and squeakers of storm men
hasn't school started yet kids get off
your phones and pay attention to your
third grade teachers science lectures
she doesn't get paid enough to deal with
your [ __ ] well if you could have made
that more wordy maybe I wouldn't have
gotten bored by the end of it the
animatronics aren't meant to scream when
you think see you in five nights at
freddys the game just has access to your
webcam while they play is there is there
any way to make the box in the left-hand
corner of your videos smaller or of a
lower resolution you will never be a
groan alright looks like I'm getting to
the point where the less creative ones
aren't there alright your face resembles
a puzzle miscarriage okay I made to the
bottom of the page of the top ones so
I'm pretty sure that's all the really
good ones so that was really fun that
was a lot of fun so I hope you guys
enjoyed that as much as I did I loved
that so much I loved it so much I was
like all my friends while we were I was
waiting for this Apple we're reading it
behind my back and they were telling me
how good they were and I was like oh I
can't read is still badly so if you want
to check out more roast you can check
out this subreddit there's a link in the
description below if you want to check
out more the comments on this one in
particular checking out links also there
thank you everybody so much for 9
million subscribers thanking everyone
for joining you this far on this journey
thank you everyone who show me support
and hey you know what like life would be
boring if there weren't people throwing
creative insults out there so I really
hope to see more of this in the future
because like to be honest I know my
flaws I know my flaws very well and I
know where of like my strengths are so
it's good to see a mixture of both
sometimes a little bit humbling is
humbling in the way good either way
thank you everybody so much for watching
I hope you have a wonderful day after
this check out this subreddit there
are a lot of laughs to be at here thanks
again everybody and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye